For this main video,
it's worth saying explicitly at the start
that the obvious actual goal
is to achieve happiness,
not misery.
But you, like me,
might find the advice on happiness
kind of tiresome.
Almost irritating.
So it might be more useful to think
about how to achieve the opposite.
And thus, to see how the actions we might
take work against us.
And happiness is a topic that is
unusually well-suited to this mental inversion.
My dear viewers,
do not take the main video as literal advice.
I want all of you to find your own happiness.
And that's why I made this video.
Good luck.
Why are you still here?
Click the video on the upper-left corner.